that's where we are actually I'm serious
I'm just a visual person all right I'll
vote for you hey guys I'm off the grid
for August but my friend billmar
probably maybe said something that kind
of made sense but also didn't make sense
and I'm working on you Bill come on man
you'll get there this is cool I hope
this isn't too uh personal but I mean it
in the best possible way I think the
fact that you are who you are again if
we could just get rid of all of the
Trump stuff
um uh and that you are a person of color
is an advantage I think it is the right
moment I think it's in happening in the
right party a party that is very sort of
uh
you know they know that in the past in
the recent past including sometimes the
present they are racist and they happen
I mean Reagan started his campaign in
Philadelphia Mississippi which was a a
undeniable signal that he was okay with
my here's my situation but they're
better than they were and the fact that
they like you
that they like you
and I think they're going to like you a
lot more I mean they're just getting to
know you the people that know me like
six months ago right so here's here's I
think they're better than they used to
be but they're still a lot of races I
think I think that that party I I think
there's a lot of I mean
what do you call racism when you say you
want you know I mean I'll give you a
quote
the remedy to pass discrimination is
present discrimination the remedy to
present discrimination is future
discrimination that's racism too that's
candy it's candy you know you're all
over it so
my point is down with that look if
you're like a psychologist and you got a
patient that comes in with anxiety
you don't shot them down by saying don't
be anxious don't be anxious don't be
anxious you're right it's they're going
to have a battle of anxiety I think
where we are in this country with
respect to racism I'll use an analogy
based on you you know lighting that and
watching that you know taper out is it's
like the last burning embers of racism
that's where we are actually I'm serious
I'm just a visual person all right I'll
vote for you you got me with that one it
really is and so the last what I don't
want to do is write is that's burning
out I don't want to come in and throw
kerosene on it butane don't be racist
that's what we'd be doing foreign
foreign